about seaplanes and
two different designs you can have a
boat whole seaplane or you can have a
conventional airplane on floats so there
at the bottom left is a part of the
Grumman series they made a huge number
of these around world war ii and many of
them are still flying you can see always
probably 15 or 20 of these at Oshkosh
every year in different sizes the
widgeon is the smallest the albatross is
the biggest I forget if that's like a
martin mars up there on the top left
there were some huge truly huge sea
planes boeing Sikorsky and martin I
think all made huge sea planes during
World War two and just before the bush
pilots don't like the small boat hold
sea planes like the lake amphibian and I
guess the icon they probably wouldn't
like if it ever did ship up there to
Alaska I think one issue with the boat
hull planes is they're very hard to dock
you have to design some kind of special
dock for them they really designed more
for beaching whereas the float planes
very naturally come up to a dock like a
boat that's one issue so yeah you might
think those float planes look so
unstable but the bush pilots love them
it's hard to get on and off the water
which is why a practical sea plane
really should have in most cases a
turboprop engine to get enough power to
really get off the water so we do have
an Alaska locally it's called mean
there's a fair amount of seaplane flying
up there these are a couple US
government planes if you want to know
why your taxes are going in the
direction that they're going look on the
bottom right that was the government's I
saw these two planes side-by-side on the
ramp Portland Maine has a wonderful FBLA
called Mack jets which is very
hospitable they have crew cars
reasonably priced hundred low-lead
they're really just operating it as a
gift to the piston crowd of course
they're really there for the turbine as
a business they're there for the jets
but it's a great place that you can use
and jump in the crew car going to town
but anyway on the ramp I happen to see
there's a little piston Cessna on floats
that they bought
fifteen or 20 years ago for Fish and
Wildlife patrol or something I think
this is a federal government airplane
and now they have this monster thing
that they were they're replacing it with
it has a fire-breathing turboprop engine
probably cost five times as much per
hour to run okay every year in September
there is the Moosehead Lake seaplane
fly-in and you might ask can you fly in
there and an East Coast
Aero Club plane that you've rented the
answer is yes although you probably
can't fly back out if you choose the
lake as your landing destination but
there is a wheeled Airport there as well
that's pretty reasonable I think it's
about a 4,000 foot runway so if the
weather is nice that's a great place to
go up in Moosehead Lake it's a long
drive it's about probably a five hour
drive from here the hard thing about sea
planes is if the float is all the way in
the water it will never take off there's
so much drag you have to get up on the
step which if you're a boater
corresponds to getting up on the plane I
guess of a planing hull so basically you
can't have the entire float in the water
if you ever want to take off let's just
show a short YouTube video here
we have no sound oh well that's fine so
you can see this caravan on floats I
think it's a caravan it's beginning to
get up on the step and finally it can
break loose anyway that's how it's done
crosswind landing this is how it's done
according to the FAA
so the FAA is mission the FAA is mission
is in addition to regulating aviation
they're explicitly supposed to promote
aviation
it's a rare agency so part of their
mission is to encourage people to fly
and this is the best that they can do
for sea planes so it does tell you like
I was telling you the problem with sea
planes is you know if you make a if you
make an error on Hanscom on runway 2 9
first of all it's 150 feet wide and the
gear on your airplane might only be you
know 10 feet wide so you can slide quite
a bit left to right before you even
leave the pavement if you do leave the
pavement you're skipping along the grass
and the owner is going to have some
harsh words for you perhaps but
otherwise nothing too dramatic is going
to happen glass this is the FAA this is
the FAA is glassy water landing
demonstration so if there's no wind at
all you might think that's great that's
perfect for seaplane flying it's hard to
judge where the water is a little bit of
wind that causes some ripples on the
water makes it much easier to judge your
distance so here's your alternatives you
can not flare it all and crash into the
water that way or you can flare too high
and then crash into the water
what's that those are the only
possibilities that's the question radar
all radar altimeter
[Music]
the question is do you wait until VR to
take off or you just wait till the
floats cleared the water and take off
that's a good question
it's so inefficient to be dragged into
the water I think you lift out of the
water just as soon as you can and then
you'll probably you know float you'll
fly along the ground effect for a little
bit and then finally take off but yeah
just like this just like on a soft field
like you know slightly muddy grass or
something the best thing you can do is
to get away from the surface that's
dragging dragging on you
great question all right here's a
docking and beaching so one challenge
with the seaplane if you're all by
yourself is you have to be tremendously
agile and nimble to sort of get out of
the plane kill the engine
scramble around usually the front of the
airplane and the propeller because
you're sitting on the left and I don't
know the passengers are gonna go off on
the right and tie up the airplane to the
dock it's very hard to do it's one of
the hardest things I think about sea
planes and also if the Magneto's aren't
perfectly grounded airplane engines can
start by themselves after saying you
know we shouldn't tell you stuff that's
scary you know if it's not perfectly
grounded by that switch and you don't
starve the engine of the fuel by killing
it with the mixture it may be able to
start all by itself at least run for you
know half a rotation or full rotation
and hurt somebody so you know you always
want to be cautious around propellers
and not spin them but of course if
you're trying to get around the front -
for your seaplane repellers the most
obvious thing to grab on to anyway
that's I don't think I would ever want
to fly a seaplane unless there were dock
handlers who were gonna deal with the
that part of you know welcoming the
airplane to the dock and tying it all
out but of course the folks in Alaska
they do this all the time
so I have have respect when you see a
seaplane so there are a lot of bad
things that you can do believe it or not
landing in the sea is something that's
almost impractical it's almost
impossible on a seaplane because there's
too much in the way of waves they're
really for harbors rivers lakes if you
have more than a foot of so if the waves
are more than about a foot it just hangs
up the sea plane so much that it'll be
damaged landing the amphibious playing
with the wheels down is one of the most
common mistakes you might think software
would fix this and you know you have a
database of where all the runways are in
the US you have a database of you know
where the lakes are and other bodies of
water but you don't even really need
that so you could have a lot and you
have it you could have a camera out at
the front that can tell the difference
between water and not water so you would
think that the airplane would provide
significant assistance in configuring an
amphibious plane without either wheels
down for a hard surface or the floats or
just the bare floats for water and
there's there's very little of that
unfortunately there's certainly nothing
like the intelligence that I'm
describing you know you might be able to
like press a button and have that plane
tell you or the synthesized voice is an
aftermarket thing you know the wheels
are down for runway landing or something
so one common thing that people forget
and not that common but this is an
illustration of why you might want a to
pilot crew but there's a video that's
linked here from the slide about a
father it sounds like a good pilot in a
careful pilot he is with the son and he
left the wheels down landed in the water
flipped over and the son was killed
really tragic so watch that if you want
to cry but anyway I think it's a good
illustration of you know seaplane out
amphibious sea print operation is a
great example of where two pilot crew
with the checklist would be very
unlikely to have that kind of accident
so it also illustrates you know how it's
too bad that these manned airplanes
don't have 1/100 of the intelligence of
a DJI drone they're rare exceptions like
I said at Burning Man
you know the terrain warning system had
to be silenced because it was freaking
out that we were not going to make it
even though there was a 5,000 foot
temporary runway that had been rolled
out there by the burners the uber
burners okay salt waters you know people
do this commercially but you know the
airplane has to be hosed off every day
because the salt water is corrosive even
to aluminum question swimmers and
boaters in lakes and harbors yeah that's
one of the challenges of sea planes you
know if you're cleared land in an
airport the air traffic controller has
looked out of the runway you know made
sure that there's no other aircraft
pretty sure that there's no deer on the
runway the you know the sea plane you
have to kind of orbit around it's a
little bit like landing a helicopter off
Airport to really make sure that there's
nobody in a canoe I will tell you that
for my seaplane training up in me and I
have a seaplane rating that I got up in
Maine and there's a great school up
there called Twitchell's
but anyway yeah if you see like kayakers
they can pal pretty fast when they see
is he playing in the vicinity but yeah
there could be a log in the water so
there's just their hazards that you
can't you can't control and get rid of
so the accident rate does tend to be
higher in the military I think there's a
slide later where we talk about that
they've gotten away from sea planes and
into helicopters for that reason you
know the helicopter you can be down to
within two feet of the ground and say
you know I don't like what I see I'm
gonna go somewhere else the propeller
tends to get beaten up you'll see some
seaplane designs or the propellers you
know up high and in the back and that's
to keep the water you know propellers
going you're supersonic speeds at the
tips
so if it gets water on it it'll it'll be
eroded same deal with flying your
airplane and heavy rain you can get
erosion on the leading edges of the wing
and on the prop alright so yeah the
seaplane pilot skills include a lot more
judgment there's some extent there'll be
the dimensions of these lakes and you
know even in Alaska there's even a
lighted water runway but generally
speaking you don't have a lot of
information to go by so you've got to
evaluate all the stuff by yourself one
thing you can do I'll use this coffee
cup is an example you can usually see
where the winds coming from if there's
trees all around the lake the lake will
be calm right next let's assume this
coffee cup is a tree the lake will be
calm and glassy right next to the tree
and that tells you the wind is coming
from this direction because that part of
the lake is being sheltered from the
wind
so you can't actually read the wind off
the lake by looking at which parts are
rippled and which parts are glassy but
you still have to decide you know right
are there floating logs in the water are
there swimmers are there boats here are
some unusual skills that you have to
have well you might have to have after
maintenance or to get their plane
maintained
[Music]
well
all right so that was straight floats in
the grass so at the end of the season
you want to get the airplane maintained
there's not a lot of airplane mechanics
hanging around the typical lake so you
just land it on the floats in the grass
at an airport and what about when you
want to get it out
Oh
you had to get the sound watch that at
home
[Music]
so as I said earlier the problem with
you know seaplanes is that you know it's
just a lot less forgiving than hard
surface runway which is the most
forgiving environment you can enhance
that safety with the two pilot crew
especially an experienced seaplane pilot
or there's stuff that'll be on the test
you can learn about accident reporting
so this is a different part of the
federal regulations this is the part
that relates the that regulates what the
NTS PD NTSB does National Transportation
Safety Board so first they define what
an accident is so there has to be you
know a serious injury and they define if
you go in there they kind of define what
a serious injury is and I think
substantial damage to the aircraft if
it's just the landing gear that's a bit
trashed I don't think that qualifies if
somebody dies within 30 days of the
accident it becomes fatal here's your
here's your definition of serious injury
not too much fun you have to immediately
notify the NTSB if the flight controls
malfunction they don't really care if
the lycoming our continental piston
engine fails in some way but if the
flight controls fail and you can't Bank
your session or Piper or cirrus that's
something they want to hear about if
more than half of your glass cockpit
goes dark they want to hear about that
I think 830 . 15 is kind of in in the
test something it's those time periods
like report report within 10 days of the
accident oh yeah and your required info
when notifying okay
so the bottom line on seaplanes is that
it does combine you know the hazards of
a boat and a plane and therefore you
need the skills of both a sailor and a
pilot
to manage those hazards on the other
hand I think it's a lot of fun you know
when the icon first came out at $100,000
and change I thought well this would be
great well you just get one of these
we'll split it four ways we'll keep it
at Hanscom and then you know we'll go up
for a 15-minute flight to New Hampshire
slash and - come back and it'll be
really cool now that it's a four hundred
thousand dollar airplane you know it's
not enough it's the question is let's go
back to that slide
yeah file report within seven days if an
aircraft is overdue so that means you
expected an airplane to come back from
the fishing camp in Alaska and it hasn't
returned so you don't know if it's
crashed or not that was like me remember
I told you that story about landing at
PDK in Atlanta and I didn't forgot to
close my flight plan and so my my
diamond star was considered overdue and
I kept rejecting calls from an
unfamiliar phone number my proudest
moment all right so insurance is kind of
expensive as any other de specially for
the amphibs Strait an airplane on
straight flows isn't that much more
expensive to insure than a regular
airplane actually that's a great way to
evaluate risk if an insurance company is
willing to write a policy first that's
not on floats it can't be all that can't
be all that dangerous but like I said
the military has decided what's do most
of the things we used to do with sea
planes with helicopters question
so aren't sure we've met personal
insurance so I don't belong but we
ourselves are
I think question is just your like
regular medical insurance cover an
injury from plying sure yeah there's no
exclusion for that I think sometimes if
you get like an umbrella liability
policy they say well that's great but
we're not gonna like to add five million
dollars if you injure somebody with your
Cessna so they can have exclusions AOPA
has a big insurance business actually
selling life insurance at pretty
reasonable rates to pilots so there
again that tells you you know when your
friend says you know you're stupid why
would you fly a Piper or a Cessna you
know that thing's old it doesn't look
safe you can say well like insurance
companies aren't stupid and they have a
huge business marketing life insurance
to the members of AOPA who are all
flying little airplanes like this and
you know it's only a 10 percent higher
rate than you know what you can get in
the market elsewhere of course pilots
are healthier than the that's that's
that's one issue right since pilots by
definition have passed a medical exam
they tend to be a little bit healthier
than average same reason like the
military the death rate of people who
serve in the military is quite a bit
lower than the death rate of the same
age people who are in the civilian
workforce
partly because not that many of them are
actually you know in combat and partly
because the military rejects people who
are unhealthy so you're not going to die
of cancer at age 23 if you're in the
military because they would have not let
you enlist probably if they saw that you
were suffering from the beginning stages
of cancer all right light sport flying
boats array is fun this is a real one
there's 700 of these out there and they
sell it as a kit and they also sell it
as a built airplane so here it is look
how much fun some somebody put one of
these on a yacht and flew it in all
different parts of the world you know
they would take off I guess they would
winch it down into the water take off
fly around and then winch it back up and
I think they were in some fairly open
oceans at the time none of the things
survived so that's pretty cool they
stuff a Garmin g3x glass cockpit in
there that's the same that the things
that Gabe gamebird has the light sport
folks have a lot of flexibility it has a
Rotax engine which is conventional the
icon a5 is the airplane see look look at
Oshkosh there there booth is always
packed people love it people want it and
it's one of the few airplanes that's
marketed to people that don't have any
flying experience
I wrote a review of it in 2010 saying
that it would be available until 2014 I
think it had been originally promised
for you know 2012 so it's just kind of
coming out but these composite plants
are hard to manufacture I talked to the
gamebird guys they said they spend 500
hours 500 person hours prepping the
airplane to be painted just like sanding
and smoothing everything to be painted
so I think it's just very hard to make
these things at an economical price I
still don't have sound I don't think do
we here's my review of the plane I made
this little video that was fun well I
thought it was fun I'm sure Ikon doesn't
think it's fun alright questions about
sea planes
who wants one who want who would buy an
icon if it were reasonably priced
yeah the question is you know what would
buy in my opinion B of landing in the
Great Lakes I think people do use do a
lot of flying of sea planes up in the
Great Lakes but there again you know the
Great Lakes there are harbors there are
column or areas I think they're not
really landing in the middle of the
Great Lake and then they don't say like
I just want to go to the middle of Lake
Superior and fish off the float for a
while
they're going to some destination and by
definition you know the destination will
have a calmer area for for boats to hang
out and it's I think there's actually a
commercial seaplane service that's
starting up between Manhattan and Boston
so you'll you'll go to the there's a
seaplane I should have mentioned this
for helicopters they're held at pads all
around Manhattan so you can actually go
to the downtown Wall Street heliport
land it used to be really cheap it was
$75 an hour for parking I think or maybe
25 it was I don't know it was it was not
that much more than parking in a car go
and have lunch now they've leased those
helmet pads to some government crony
monopoly that owns all three of them and
they crank the rates up by a factor of
four on you know immediately but anyway
they I don't know if it's the same
company but they have a seaplane a
public seaplane port they're on the East
River and this I think it's a cape air
affiliate maybe that's going to start
operating downtown to downtown and
assessment caravan on floats
you